hello there Internet I'm John Oliver
host of last week tonight except this
week I have been relegated to YouTube
like some kind of piano playing cat I
would like to take this opportunity to
appreciate and respond to some of the
fan mail that we have received it's not
literal mail of course because I host
the television show in 2014 not a
Farmers Almanac from 1842 so so I will
be replying to several comments from the
last week tonight YouTube page a few
weeks ago for instance we did a story on
America's nuclear arsenal and the
discourse it set off was let's just say
it was full of words a YouTube user
actually wrote and this is very touchy I
don't even understand why the audience
is laughing which which I hope was a
comment on the seriousness of the
subject matter and not a referendum on
the comedy contained either way it
cannot possibly be more hurtful to the
comment on the same video reading John
Oliver's face does look like a parrot
there's a lot to feel uncomfortable
about there but primarily there's the
word does like he's agreeing with
someone yes good point that man's face
is rather parrot like why isn't this TV
show more about wanting crackers it
makes no sense
my cracker jokes parrots do it parrots
look moving on for instance more
recently a viewer wrote to us regarding
the practice of native advertising in
the news and saying unsubscribed when
the ship talk on CodeRed started when
you mock the second best cherry soda you
dun goofed now listen listen i dumb
goofed before but not in a dog's age in
fact the last time i dun goofed this bad
i reckon the call was as high as an
elephant's eye but but if you are
willing to abandon this show because i
made fun of your second favorite cherry
soda then goodbye sir favourite flavour
of cherry soda probably also has a
second favourite smelling brand of
gasoline but but my favorite comment in
recent weeks was this one from the very
same video which was in spanish and it
really touched me
to think that my comedy had crossed the
language barrier finally i thought i
truly understand what it means to live
la vida loca until that is I went to a
Google Translation page and pressed
translate and saw the message was
Spanish for son of a
like you see on TV makes me sick of
the world which even if the translation
was clunky is certainly not a compliment
and now finally because we do not want
to leave you on a negative note here's
one one last comment from YouTube saying
this guy is brilliant
because Bruins villains is exactly what
I am if you aren't mistaking me for
anything for doing anything other than
that if you're mistaking me for instance
for doing something brilliant you are
frankly not paying any close attention
to what I'm saying so we will be back in
September on the 7th of September at 11
p.m. on HBO by which point this video
will have undoubtedly amassed enough
hateful vitriol for us to film a
follow-up thank you so much for watching
a special thanks to our YouTube
commenters down there you are all
brilliant every single one
[Applause]